we have more news not related to the
coronavirus Canada is reeling from the
deadliest mass shooting in its history
at least 16 people were killed when a
gunman reportedly dressed like a police
officer went on a weekend rampage across
central Nova Scotia investigators say
the suspect is also dead
Errol Barnett shows how the violence
unfolded authorities in Canada say the
12-hour shooting rampage began in a
rural town late Saturday and ended at
this gas station around 30 miles away
witnesses described hearing gunfire and
police later said the suspect was dead
it's just something that I never ever
expect to happen here this close to home
the gunmen believed to be 51 year old
Gabriel Wortman was allegedly disguised
in a police uniform and tried to make
his car look like a cruiser the impact
of this incident will extend from one
end of the province to the other
according to authorities the victims
were shot in several locations including
inside and outside of a home fires were
also set police have not yet released a
motive countless families are in
mourning today among the dead
Heidi Stevenson a 23-year veteran of the
Royal Canadian Mounted Police the mother
of two was killed while responding to
the scene mass shootings are not as
common in Canada as they are here in the
United States the country overhauled its
gun laws back in 1989 after a gunman
opened fire at a college killing 14
people that is now the second deadliest
shooting in the country's history Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau called the
violence senseless and said on Sunday
that quote in moments like these we come
together to support one another
the CBS this morning Errol Barnett very
rough morning